even in the midst of this remake and
reboot friendly era a lot of horror
movies are just waiting to be remade and
they could be genuinely spectacular keep
your mind open and your grumblings to a
minimum because here's a look at some
horror movies that legitimately deserve
a remake ever since its released in 1997
this Paul WS Anderson space chiller has
divided audiences over whether it's a
good time or one hell of a terrible
movie one thing everyone can agree on is
that the film in which a space crew
investigates an abandoned ship only to
discover it may be a gateway to hell is
a product of its time which hasn't
exactly aged well in its defense it also
suffered a terrible production history
that heavily impacted the final cut as
fans of the film will tell you this
visceral sci-fi horror outing was given
a preposterous ly tight post-production
deadline on top of studio demands for
excessive edits apparently this deeply
affected the pacing and visual effects
of the theatrical cuts and it also meant
some of the film's scariest and glorious
set pieces were scrapped the film's
notorious lost footage was unwisely
packaged off to a Transylvania salt mine
and the resulting damage was apparently
irrevocable in 2019 it was reported that
Adam Wingard is developing a TV
adaptation of event horizon which could
be great as long as it delivers all the
vital unseen moments and plot
developments that were sadly scrapped
from the original event horizon deserves
a remake that can finally fulfill the
gnarly nasty vision that neither
Anderson nor the movie's audience ever
got to see what happened to your eyes
we will need eyes to say this stylish
1983 horror movie from director Tony
Scott has it all and still makes for a
great if quaint viewing experience The
Hunger uses 80s goth and New Wave
culture as its backdrop to explore a
story that revolves around addiction
sexual politics and the anguish of aging
The Hunger follows a vampire named
Miriam who takes lovers that she turns
into vampires but there's a catch while
she lives forever never aging her
vampiric lovers grow old and frail while
forced to subsist on human blood in 2009
Warner Brothers was reportedly working
on a remake of The Hunger though clearly
that idea seemed to have been abandoned
fairly early in development while fans
of the original underground hit revealed
they weren't happy at the prospect of a
remake it certainly deserves one it's
worth noting that the original ending of
The Hunger was changed that the studio's
requests to leave the film open for
sequels something cast member Susan
Sarandon has said she regrets on the DVD
commentary she said the powers that be
rewrote the ending and decided that I
wouldn't die nobody knew that was going
on and I thought that was a shame the
ambiguous ending of The Hunger is
certainly something that could be fixed
with a remake a 3d remake of the 1987
cult classic the gate was in
pre-production in 2009 but sadly died in
development director Tibor tokachi
who helmed the original told birth
movies death in 2012 we were on board
and involved in the remake for a while
and then we had a difference of opinion
and we parted ways I don't even know if
they shot it or not I can't get a
straight story Alex winter a Bill and
Ted Fame was also on board to direct the
remake which he planned to use as a
launch pad for an entire pg-13 horror
franchise but and unfortunately never
got off the ground
a more modern remake of the gates could
be perfect for reflecting youthful fears
of being powerless in the face of a
world that seems out of control
rightful masters are jealous watching
mankind with a hatred that is as
boundless as the Stars an American
remake of Battle Royale has been at
various levels of development since the
original Japanese release became a cult
hit though various obstacles have
prevented it from coming to fruition
telling the story of a class of school
children in a totalitarian society who
were forced to fight to the death until
a lone survivor emerges the film's
themes remain painfully relevant in
modern America sadly that relevance has
hit a little too close to home with one
attempt at a remake paused following the
Virginia Tech massacre that same remake
was officially dropped in 2012 out
appears that it would look like a ripoff
of the Hunger Games
even though battle royale was written
years before the first Hunger Games book
still the potential to develop battle
royale for the next generation still
exists
given the current sensitivity over mass
violence especially when it comes to
children it's likely to be met with
controversy but maybe that's exactly the
reason why this film deserves to be
remade centered around a pack of
practical joke loving college students
who end up being picked off by a
mysterious killer with a cruel sense of
humor April Fool's Day is quite possibly
one of the dumbest and most fun slasher
movies of its time leading the ill-fated
group of teens is an unconventional
final girl named Muffy st. John an
eccentric wealthy teenager with plenty
of mansion space to share with her
ill-fated coeds April Fool's Day is
packed full of ridiculous plot twists
and red herrings as well as obnoxious
rich kids getting slaughtered in
ridiculous ways in short it's everything
you could walk from the genre the film
actually did receive a remake in 2008
but the direct-to-video film was unable
to tap into the core comedic appeal of
the original with the rise of internet
pranksters turned viral stars like
YouTube celebrities were in what can
only be described as a prankster
Renaissance a new modern remake may not
retain the same cheesy charm as the
original but it could still be timely
and huge amounts of fun especially if it
means seeing YouTube pranksters getting
their hilariously hideous comeuppance
the horror genre is long overdue for the
arrival of a smarts grown-up slasher
franchise while most horror fans would
likely prefer an original take on what
that would look like there's something
intriguing about the prospect of
remaking horror satire the slumber party
massacre from modern audiences the
subversive cult classic from director
Amy Holton Jones and writer Rita Mae
brown
was
missed as little more than a derivative
slasher by numbers when it was released
in 1982 dogs in the trash again so go
take care of it what do you think I am
stupid I'm not going out there alone in
the dark since then the film has been
hailed for skewing the overt misogyny of
the slasher genre in its revolt against
genre tropes Jones has expressed some
regrets about having to include
gratuitous nudity in the film's early
shower scene which she said was
unavoidable producer Roger Corman
insisted on the scenes inclusion because
according to Jones nudity was more
important to Roger Corman than sex and
you know he has to sell the thing it's a
horror trope that's been gradually
forced out of the genre and even
subverted in modern entries like
midsummer shall factory acquired
Corman's library in 2018 and have
reportedly expressed interest in a
potential remake there are currently
plenty of incredible female horror
directors who could take a confident
swing at it so here's hoping they get
the chance to make their bloody mark the
return of the Living Dead continues to
be one of the most fun horror movies
ever made and one which provides a neat
time capsule and celebrating some of the
subversive youth culture of the eighties
The Return of the Living Dead is pure
punk rock right down to the set dressing
and outfits worn by the cast that punk
spirit includes authentic depictions of
punk culture but it also has an
aggressively irreverent
anti-establishment stance which is
emphatically anti-military it's rare to
find similarly authentic depictions of
young rebellious subcultures and modern
horror or anywhere in contemporary
cinema for that matter the fact that
there is no modern-day remake of The
Return of the Living Dead could be
considered a real wasted opportunity
when youth subcultures are arguably the
most visible and politically active they
happen in decades there's definitely an
argument to be made that the last decade
has given us enough zombie films and TV
shows the last a lifetime and beyond
still there's something intriguing about
discovering a fresh zombie narrative
which has a slightly different story to
tell a modern-day remake of Sugarhill
could be the one that brings fresh life
to the overdone genre as much a revenge
movie as a zombie flick this underrated
1974 blaxploitation horror film follows
a woman who summons an army of zombies
to seek revenge against the mobsters who
killed her boyfriend with an empowered
african-american woman leading the story
Sugarhill takes on feminist issues
alongside some sharp commentary
regarding racism and class most
importantly it does all of this while
still being extremely entertaining with
the current Renaissance of black horror
pushing african-american narratives and
concerns to the forefront of a genre
that hasn't always been so historically
inclusive Sugarhill could make for an
incredible mainstream Hollywood remake
that's well deserved anyone who holds a
place for this 80s classic in their
hearts will be well aware of the fact
that the Monster Squad in which a group
of witty talkative kids take on some
classic monsters in their hometown is
arguably one of the biggest influences
on the current pop culture trend of kids
versus monsters content from stranger
things to the child's play reboot and
scary stories to tell in the dark and
the new it you can't go far without
bumping into stories about children
fighting monsters in recent years
Monster Squad filmmakers Fred Dekker and
Shane Black even had to let go of their
idea of a 30 years later sequel to the
original because everyone's already
doing exactly that as Dekker put it I
thought well let's make this movie for
the people who fell in love with it when
they were kids and say where's the squad
as adults and Shane said to me well
that's it and I said yeah it's a great
idea and he goes no that's Stephen
King's it the first part of the book in
the first movie is them as kids fighting
monsters and the second movie is them as
adults fighting monsters but it's the
ubiquity of these tropes which could
actually make for a great remake of the
Monster Squad particularly if it added a
fresh modern take while parroting
current trends though nothing could beat
the original there's definitely
potential in a story that sees a bunch
of desensitized kids rolling their eyes
at the threat of a bunch of old school
classic monsters maybe a monster squad
remake could finally bring that Blum
House shared universe to permission with
a gang of kids nearly taking on the
horror studio's most notorious foes the
fact that we haven't gotten a remake
already is completely
starring Vincent Price as a sour old
thespian who enacts gastly acts of
vengeance against his worst critics this
British tongue-in-cheek horror outing is
an underrated classic the film leans
confidently into camp sensibilities and
takes great Glee and some of the most
Papa stress and elaborate murder scenes
of horror comedy history the
inspirations for each are taken from
classic deaths of various Shakespeare
plays which played perfectly to early
70s British audiences when the film was
released although theatres of blood
continues to enjoy a strong cult
following it's difficult to imagine
young audiences connecting with it in
quite the same way however in focusing
on how critics can wield their power the
underlying themes of theatre of blood
remain familiar after all we live in a
time when anyone can take to social
media to be as careless and cruel as
they like about arts and the people who
make it check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite horror movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]